der demokratische us senator dick durbin
hat am freitag in chicago vorwürfe gegen
präsident donald trump bestätigt der
soll bei einem treffen im weißen haus
zitat vulgäre sprache genutzt und
afrikanische länder und auch haiti
wiederholt als schiphol countries zu
dort drecksloch länder bezeichnet haben
nach eigener aussage hatte durban selbst
bei der zusammenkunft über die
auswirkungen von bestimmten
regierungsplänen auf migrantengruppen
berichtet vor durbans bestätigung hatten
mehrere insider berichtet trampe
folgenden satz gesagt warum wollen wir
diese leute aus afrika hier haben das
sind drecksloch länder wir sollten mehr
leute aus norwegen haben
trump selbst hatte sich am freitag über
den kurznachrichtendienst twitter zu
wort gemeldet niemals habe er etwas
herabwürdigende es über haiti oder china
gesagt dass trump sei eine erfindung der
demokraten reporter nachfragen nach
seinen kommentaren und einer möglichen
entschuldigung schien trampe am freitag
im weißen haus zu überhören
in haiti aber auch hier in nigeria haben
das angebliche äußerungen für entsetzen
gesorgt auf den straßen von lagos
zeigten sich bewohner am freitag
betroffen
das schaffst du etwas über afrikanische
länder sagt ist wirklich wirklich sehr
böse und ich denke dass jedes
afrikanische land etwas daraus lernen
sollte bleibt in euren ländern und
arbeitet mit dem was ihr dort vorfindet
ich bin mir sicher dass die situation
waren weit besser wird das kommt nicht
ganz unerwartet von jemandem der natur
wir schon kennen
ich denke das ist eine bemerkung die nur
jemand wie er machen kann
wir als afrikaner sollten uns nun auf
uns selbst besinnen wird die ursache
dieses depot allerdings auch die
vereinten nationen äußerten sich empört
dass sein schockierende und beschämende
kommentare des us-präsidenten man könne
nicht umhin diese als rassistisch zu
bezeichnen so rupert colville un
sprecher für menschenrechte sind kommt
zu uns